foreign
Erickson with my friend Aaron hello oh that's
such a quick nice hello look at us wearing scary
t-shirts look at those words ghost spooky stuff
ghosts we're screaming we're gonna watch Saw Three
three I hope they cut up more people what do
you think it's gonna be I think they're gonna
cut up a lot of people and make us uh really yeah
I think it's gonna be a lot of torture points okay
that's what he thinks you guys need to remember
to leave a like type in the computer and you
ought to leave a comment and be nice and cool
and kind and all you have to ring the bell
and don't forget we call you super sexy if you
join on patreon patreon.com and then you get to
watch me and Aaron watch the entire movie a full
reaction and watch along sync up with your own
copying we can't show you the whole movie like
you sit there at home with your popcorn with
your candy you watch with us the whole thing
one happy family all synced up watching saw
three that way you're not like I have to watch
all three alone you don't you watch it with
ah and also don't forget John and Greg cover
exclusive shows over there with reactions and
watch alongs and they've got a lot of stuff
it's like real exclusive over there if you
get on the patreon so you got it you gotta you
gotta know what's up so get over there get on it
get on it are you ready for start three oh my
God Wrath I'm so ready okay let's get into it
game over
oh my God all right immediately what wait
this is picking up for the last one oh it is
okay all right come on you can get out of this
Steve Wahlberg I believe in you yeah come on
yes use the shoe use other objects to
get things across the room we've learned
from the last movie we like this we love
this move anything on your body is a tool
it was empty it was empty empty clip
to the light it's to the flashlight wow
that was kind of dumb oh no dude okay
this is interesting because this one is a direct
continuation of saw two what I felt like the first
one was was not this yeah yeah the second one
I'm also like that girl's not in the bathtub
anymore though or around right the new well
yeah because she came and closed the door on him
that's not gonna work but they tried that
in 1987 he did not cut through his cord
he Baroque uh didn't he break it I think he
broke it he broke the saw last night right yeah
oh it's the [__] oh I hated him
oh my God that's an old foot is that
from number one yeah oh that's number
one foot uh-uh that's Mr barky's foot
yeah we got a number one foot number
two body it's rough in here it's
rough in these streets in this room
okay I mean the other guy I feel like he
bled out I think so I think he bled out
bro come on okay I wasn't ready
I wasn't ready I mean she left
him alive she could have killed him
so like just call out for her oh no
on foot
[Music]
oh my God no
no no no no no
God
why God too much we all are getting right to
it oh my God that was probably the worst thing
[Music] oh my God I was not ready for
that I really liked though that he went
for it immediately yeah you can't say he's
he's not uh determined he's not committed
yeah literally just a direct
continuation of the events wow
oh new character yeah I know him
you know him not personally he's
just in stuff he's not one of your friends
your problem was first on the scene Gary
I'm glad she's still in it I really
liked her I think she's a good actress
it's not detective Matthews who
is it where are they they're in
a different location right oh God wait
what he's holding place by these chains
[Applause] oh no oh no thank you jeans
in a classroom oh no no no no no no no no
oh it's the around the mouth that kills me I can't
oh my God why Jesus despite all of the advantages
live or die try um okay I mean
for sure you're probably gonna
die right oh yeah they just showed
him like what happens the aftermath
oh please I was really hoping he didn't show us
what happened to that guy like
in in real time all he had to do
is release himself and meet you the chains see
because I'm wondering though if he pulled his skin
it wouldn't do that though you know what I mean
all he had to do oh God we're going back God
yeah cause I'm saying if it's clipped to the skin
that's why I'm wondering like he died but I feel
like you pull those from the skin you um right
okay see he did one all right I think you're
just bleeding from his mouth dude oh my God yeah
all you have to do that guy had a point because
this is way worse this is infinitely worse
oh my God no no no no no no no no no no
why is it like just say he did it quick like we
don't want to see anymore this hurts me oh my God
physically hurting me right now oh God yeah I was
like please do not show me that it is on his ding
dong because I cannot right now Jake says game was
to get out before the ball went off door welded
shut the guy couldn't get out if he wanted to well
that's because jigsaw is a girl now so maybe she's
like switching it up oh could be yeah one other
tag teaming right I think he was like is he not
dead yet he's not dead yet maybe he didn't look
too good in that car from the last time I know
he looked like he was close to his deathbed
yeah recognize my eyes closed [Music] why how
laughs interesting now we're following her as
the lead and choose to support last time yeah
oh what nope is the tape how is
this live exactly that's weird
okay yep yep as you should
oh my God no
where is it
no oh no how is it in the tape and in the I just
doesn't it she's already dead I like
oh she's don't like it oh okay oh God
oh my God is that acid oh my God is that is
that freaking acid it'll melt your face off
oh and it's in the oh that's her
keto escape and she probably has
to put her hand in there oh my
God I hate this I hate this um
[Music]
reach in and take it awful awful awful awful
I'm sure it's not bad it's just maybe it's just
Sprite maybe it's just Sprite it takes
the skin right down to the bone Aaron
oh my goodness nope girl it's in the rib cage I
hate this you're gonna have to do it you have no
choice oh my God oh my God no no don't don't tip
it don't tip it it's gonna tip on you don't burn
your face oh my God girl come on now it's
just Sprite it's just oh my God it's just
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
oh my God oh my God hurry no oh my God
can she even use that hand can you get
it to the other hand no no this is my theater
dance I hate it if you drop that key girl I'm
gonna be so angry oh my God she got what's
happening no no yeah how does it come out
how does it come out she's
coming in yeah big old reveal
ah no no hate it why what no no
no no oh holy junk that was awful she put her
hand in the acid to open it up why does she let
her go I got more characters Tuesday I thought
you started 11. this movie's rough y'all so he's
I was not prepared this is this is worse
immediately than the first two yeah can we just
talk for five minutes relation
no problems what's wrong
what is it you want from me
Chris a divorce damn oh okay Lynn
pressure down to 70. oh it's a kid I
gotta crack his chest damn no we're
gonna Trail the right side I'm doing
it a Russian bear stats are improving
she seems mad why because it wasn't protocol
oh did she lose a kid I see a kid signed to Mommy
and we didn't see a kid up in there maybe that's
why they're going through divorces absolutely
they're both going through grief and isolating
he's about to get kidnapped by
jigsaw or by someone in a pig mask
I don't feel like coming no no okay
yep you called it on the hairy pig mask I don't
know why they gotta have hair no thank you oh
jigsaw is not gonna kill himself I mean I'm gonna
come to a little puppet trying to kidnap people
we gotta have your big scary a big Persona
get your figure on get you get your Pig on
could that go oh so many two pigments and a
lot of weapons a lot of torture see like this
kind of room would excite me if it was for
Pure Revenge but right now we're just like
killing people out of like because he's a psycho
all right killing people you don't even know
jig sanctuary there she is there's our lady jigsaw
oh he's still alive oh dang
buddy oh she kidnapped him to
help him because with his cancer
yeah do you remember me consumer
you're being tested your will is being tested
live no what is this what are you doing to
me you're gonna torture her to save you are
those wearing as linked to my heart rate monitor
bullets when you move out of range an explosion
will go off in that collar your life and my life
will end simultaneously wow we have another test
subject if he completes all of his tests and
John is still breathing and you're free to
go it is bullets shotgun I don't think she's
gonna be free to go one thing I will say I do
appreciate appreciate about these movies is
that each one is like vastly different from
the last one they don't have that yeah repeating
the same like structure that sequels usually have
it's a guy in a box yeah hello
and
just become your tomb Sierra
what's your angle on this
ouch
wow how many times do I have to tell
you before you get it in your head oh
no no you're just nothing you
don't touch things in Dylan's room
stop I said he lost a daughter
right he was a son yeah
this poor girl I mean she lost her brother she
just wants to sleep with this stuffed animal
s
okay what happened did you you saw him and then
you had your reaction like five seconds later no
like I'm with the pig mask I just I didn't know
I didn't register no it really didn't I was like
the door's closing okay he left a gun there I was
gonna be like don't leave the gun there with the
kid and then I registered hairy pig mask I hairy
pig mask is freaky it's freaky freaky okay that
just the guy just left the daughter there he left
he left the dog I also with the gun so somebody
maybe the daughter will be locked up and it's
like play this game and you can get her out but
the kids into this man I didn't mention that he
just said you'll get to meet your son's killer who
he's obsessed with that like he wants to kill
the guy open the door open the door Jeff yeah
that the guy okay
he needs to go to the hospital and have
an operation to decompress his brain
come here I'm gonna slap her
oh no one's going to any Hospital you're giving
him painkillers for a tumor like this you need
steroids prednisone maybe we could try some
corticoster steroids you know like dexamethasone
don't know really you don't know
medicine he chose not me Amanda
jealous
of our game have been made very clear
he's [__] jealous dude he chose you
not me yeah I could have saved him I could
have saved my circuit bad [Music] okay
I can't do vomit that's gross oh
[__] not again Amanda [Music]
yeah you won't be big and bad I'm gonna
be a doctor but y'all freaking out when
[__] needs to go down oh my God this is
why I didn't choose you oh my God all right
please don't throw up in The Mask
I can't do it get it together
oh my God
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh she's gonna put the tube down or what
what's she gonna do what's she gonna do
oh God from vomit to blood very quick
[Music] assistant
is that enough for you you ready
to go to the hospital now yeah
she can be like do it here
right oh yeah we do it here
comment I need anesthetic for a procedure
like this even with an anesthetic
power drill kidnap another doctor to help her get
a whole captive staff together you guys can do it
I still need them tools though Aaron you need them
we still need that power drill as soon as you can
get you can go to the hardware store and that's
that's like a less illegal thing that she can do
to get these needs met okay we went from following
two guys in the saw game to a whole ensemble with
Ensemble people and now we're just following one
guy okay one guy's journey through oh God yep
who the f is this
all right okay that has to be a tough way to be
hanging if she's live no thank
you oh this is like a freezer
we just woke up in here just like you did
be taller just find something to stand on
come on buddy we can do it use your tippy toes
wait did the key just not work or could
he not throw another tape you see that
another table yeah you will find a woman
in front of you chained prevent her from
running much like she did on the day your son
was hit oh there's a girl who did it her name
is Danica Scott she was the only witness present
at the scene of your sons untimely demise [Music]
ah that water or acid yes it's probably water is
so cold just freezes like ice
on her I'm so sorry I'm human
Okay so the keys got to work somewhere
oh but what does that do though I mean
you're in a cold room why is the water
so torturous I don't get that oh my God that
was really fast that was unexpected oh God oh
my God what's that liquid ice you spray
it on there what the hell holy chunk
take off your sweater okay you got it
[Music] you need to like rip his hand
oh God bro take her down she's gonna shatter
into pieces it's too [__] light I mean buddy
oh that's so creative way
to die for sure it's rough
oh
my God no [Laughter] oh my God I'm
gonna have a heart attack [Laughter]
what is that
what oh God I thought I saw the hand and I was
like why are you oh God I'm gonna be touching
stuff I thought her hand went you'd be surprised
what tools can save a life [Music] what tools can
save a life well they're flashback and a flashback
as we go back there was only one over the device
a little soul patch
that's not the guy from the beginning in
the bed with the doctor right this guy no
it's not no okay yeah no because he was in a
totally different house never mind yeah yeah
I see you trying to make the connections yeah
I was just thinking like where's the twist
gonna come in yeah he was like I chose her for
that reason but I'm like What's the other right
oh jigsaw the puppet okay he fell down
who pushed the puppet also how's the uh
what I'm thinking of how's the cop in the
beginning planned all of this yeah where
is him footless footless Wahlberg no he
didn't cut it off he beat it so he could I
don't know what I'm saying that's dangling
on one nerve yeah that's got to be gone
time to go to let go time to let go
of the sun's death because behind this door is
the killer let me say there's like five tracks oh
I mean this guy learn your lesson buddy that
happened to like five minutes ago I'm in here
oh a judge presiding over your case
possessions
[Music]
oh wow let the game begin
please get me out of here please
is he gonna drop it in there with
him I think he might oh my you
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
I ate it
oh this is disgusting okay it's it's not just
pretend it's chocolate oh my god maggoty pig now
okay maybe if I just keep
watching I'll become desensitized
no I'm saying is jigsaw trying to indoctrinate
this guy to be part of the the jigsaw team
by my come to confrontation with like life and
morality and all of this all this [__] [Music]
teaching him to appreciate life for like his
relationship with what a life is worth kind of
like uh the girl we're getting all these King Pigs
that's what I need to know yeah crop Department 10
out of 10. all right and I still don't get why
the the pigs are like the thing the pig masks
the dead pigs like what yeah what's the relation
here what's the connection maybe it's because he's
saying that people are like they're like [__]
humans and pigs roll around in their own [__]
and are like you know what
I mean yeah okay it should
let it burn let it burn gotta let it burn yeah
they just keep coming okay
help me just oh good God this is
him to get out of there because I cannot
be looking at this screen no
more with that if it's if it's
[Music] oh my God I can't be doing this right
now I hope you guys are enjoying this I hope you
God this makes you want to vomit do they get
worse oh it better not to take him out of there
the next cut back too he better be out of that
juice I cannot please God the judge is alive
let me say closer than I
expected yes faster I think
are you ready to see some more things you
weren't expecting to see when you woke up
this morning yeah you mean like her hand
shaking that bad yeah girl don't you do
this all the time or his brain and skull and
my other disgusting things girl get it together
yeah don't don't good just get in there
I'm surprised you guys are having rest
oh nope I lied I immediately regretted
that saying that I was like look at them
showing restraint not showing the actual
operation and then immediately I was wrong
fill that syringe with alcohol from that
bowl wait that was weird continuity his
scissors were on there but that's okay I don't
even notice that now they're back okay [Music]
keep your mouth closed you can hear a lot of noise
oh God a lot of noise keep your mouth closed why I
don't wanna know just let's do it come on now yeah
let's just get in there are you ready for this
sawing into a prop this is not real
I put some holes in his skull
[Music] a little better that's wild
I thought that was gonna be it okay
I'm remembering now [Music]
okay he's he's okay what in the
flashback is this yeah well when
you surround your brain I'm sure you get a lot
um
yep that's a piece of your school what is this
oh God there's a film between the brain
and the skull I never knew that oh boy
your fingers
yeah right [Music]
you did the thing you're supposed to do why it's
happening still in his memory who's this girl
oh God that's too low he's dead
you're gonna blow up now lady [Music]
he's stuck in his afterlife after Alive come back
to the bright white light come on now [Music]
or did she die too is that what also brought
you over the edge she's waiting [Music] for me
that was the one that was on accident
jealous again yeah I mean she's a little captive
bird her brain is all sorts of messed up I'm gonna
kill her now what was in that is pictures right
you're about to do drugs what is this no it looks
like that looks like I think she's like what's in
there oh okay oh because she is it because she's a
is that chlorophyll there is no
turning back do you want to Hunters yes
[Music] no she's not gonna do it okay
it was in that bottle whoa
oh my God who's that uh just killed the guy
in his name I guess that's what she had to do
that was in the file wait did you kill the guy
from the first movie the photographer guy oh
she's about to drive [Music]
that's a big one girl don't don't oh she's
hiding it from him because he was like don't
be doing that no more [Music] oh and then
she got it with him since the first one
oh she just knocked him out okay this is the whole
setup for one yeah oh she's been involved because
remember she was in the very very beginning and
then she survived and then we cut to them yeah
so he turned her like right away and now okay oh
wow she's with him from the beginning okay all
right all right we're following this timeline
okay I see I see how are there ten of these
a lot of ways to kill people yeah clearly
my God this [__] is not
surviving for like 10 movies man
oh I'm just gonna give him a good sniff
you're only gonna make it worse ah yeah
chill chick chill he's trying to save him for you
oh damn girl why you keep she
been tripping the whole time
oh damn oh she's cutting her hand
right now I think also I'm like
doctor don't keep offending the woman who
can literally is like so crazy she's about
to blow your brains out like right she
calls her a freak As She's Walking Away
because we just locked the
the gate on him after the
first movie so we don't know what happened to him
okay why would you why he's already
gonna die was that necessary that's
very much not necessary to do this right now
oh wow jeez
okay okay
I'm gonna guess he didn't tell you to do that so
you just did it yeah oh this guy we're still yeah
we're still helping him that's right we didn't cut
back to remember I said it better be a fresh cut
back where there's no more Pig juice you're
so happy for it your clothes look strangely
clean yeah very clean as to be expected good Lord
very clean did they go through the washer foreign
don't bring his daughter
into this no sentence I gave
I gave 500 years not even
death nothing you're paying me
to the puzzle you hit his wife into this
another one okay is this the guy is this the
killer this is the guy the way the way he's
looking at him all right let's play
the tape so we can get the juice here
young a man whose life also changed
the day your son died [Applause]
it was your chance to make
him pay I call it the rack
God I wonder how far the arm can twist
this device is going to start twisting
oh no at the back of the box is a key
it's time to the trigger of a shotgun
are you willing have mercy to take a bullet
oh the doctor's gonna itself or the the judge
just standing there you're accomplished
you all need to find some scissors
and cut that key off three years
[Music]
oh okay [__]
who got higher than the shotgun stood on something
so when you grabbed it it would go in between your
legs this is where my brain is at right now
like would that no I would still probably get
your hand oh yeah oh my God this is just I can't
oh he's dead he is dead he won't be fast enough
the shotgun's gonna go off yes that was absolutely
that oh my God this is all this tension Jesus
I mean his limbs are already off
like just what are we doing here
oh my God this is awful this is the worst
damn yep see you later all right [Music]
nope he's already dead I mean you're so
late to the game this guy you waited way
too long every time he goes to get the key
they're dead they're already dead buddy
oh God it's gonna snap his neck
oh my god do something with the
key guys what are you doing where is the key
[Music] yeah that's a dead guy that's a
dead that's a dead brother right there
okay matrimony is always fascinated
me wires on their backs until rooms
my marriage has survived more suffering
than someone like you could ever grasp
you haven't seen anything yet
what you did say there's one
reason there's one reason why
I chose her what's the other
what
Amanda's not gonna like hearing that you're
making her jealous he wants my man I know it
was trying to steal him from me
he's completed the third test
congratulations Lynn you're
free to go and do her call
Amanda Lynn is more important
unlock her car and let her go ours
yo dude chill you promised I
promise you [__] Amanda you know
your life Iran why at least I have a family
other test subjects is that how you thought about
them I'll tell you how I felt about Eric Matthews
I don't even know how he's still
dragging it there's no way Eric Matthews
nothing from your test [Music]
oh
okay why are you attacking her
no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
remember you saw her come up in the
bathtub right didn't even know that
it was like or she came into the room
right I think so I don't remember
oh where's my son where is he junking [__] oh
right because he you remember arresting her right
here
I didn't even see that did not want to see that
yeah she's that doesn't make sense I
don't know why he would why would he
say that nobody is reborn and I'm
just a pawn in your stupid games
all right from the door Jeff
what do you want
what time's running out
think about everything that you've done
he's here now let's think about tomorrow oh
it is him
oh yeah I knew I I had okay it was him oh man
you're dumb your will is being tested [Music]
yeah okay
God he dies and now the lady blows up if
he died her collar would explode if she
that's what I mean she she would blow
like your wife's fate is in my hands
I can have an ambulance here right four minutes
be my protege he's a host of vicious implements
to take your Vengeance to
indulge your Obsession Obsession
I forgive you
yeah oh God yep nope nope
oh
yep here we go okay that's death hello Jeff
I told you that you could kill me I
am the only one where your daughter is
another one how I mean the guy's dead
how do we how do we how do we [Music]
oh wow
wow wow wow wow ah huh that was uh that was a
lot wow okay yeah I mean oh my God okay so like
holy crap holy [__] that was from
the beginning way more than one and
two oh yeah way more and also I'm
like how is he that means that
jigsaw knew prior that Jeff was gonna fail
meaning he already has a game set up but how
right if he's dead right unless we shows up
on four or something that like he taped his
neck and he saved him I don't think he'd be able
to do that this man is playing three dimensions
oh man he's still living he's
got a game all set up for Jeff
or maybe we just dude this was a great ride
but it was nasty and it was intense yeah a
lot of the times I was like please no this is
the grossest one of the three Fishers so gross
so gross wow I I will say that it's it's very
different from other horror movies that I've
seen in the in the sense that there doesn't have
a lot of scares per se it's mostly just like gross
and horrific images right but psychological
psychological stuff but it tries to have
something of a message about revenge and morality
and the choices that we make and I think a lot
of them have had that or the ones we've had
have had that kind of consistent thing going
but yeah it's uh this one was wild I will say
that I even though we didn't outright like say it
kind of how we're talking about in the first one I
did see the twist of him being the husband coming
pretty much like for most of it because right
because remember me in the beginning I'm like
is that that guy but then it was it wasn't him
it wasn't it was that she was she was cheating
on him right right but then I'm like but then why
did that guy say I want a divorce doesn't make
sense because then I'm like but if that's her Hut
that's what that's a little confusing to me but
yeah but I maybe he wanted a divorce from his wife
so he can finally be with her right right I mean
I think that's us putting the pieces together
but I think it was confusing for confusing we
were trying to link it yeah okay it was to take
off off the US off of the trail but yeah I still
felt that like okay this there's something of
a connection here because she lost a daughter
he had oh he she lost a kid he happened to have
lost a kid what are the odds that these two are
not connected because we've known at least in the
first two there's some major twists at the end
this has like become a staple of this franchise
at this point so I think because we're aware of
that we're looking for it so I think that I was
looking for that connection for like most of it
and by the time that the actual twist happened
I wasn't my mind wasn't blown like it was at the
end of the first and second movie right right
were you were you Blown Away by that twist or
I mean the twist of him showing what's
her nuts jigsaw lady um Mrs jigsaw Amanda
um The Twist of it being a test for her I
did not see coming which I did enjoy that
at the end of like this was all set up uh
just for her to like test her limits um
yeah and because you really had to put all
those pieces together to get the doctor saying
like she's worth it to you more than you know
and then him I guess knowing that like a man
is gonna shoot that girl and he he has to capture
Jeff's daughter and put her away because the test
all loops around to there at the end ah I don't
know I will tell you one thing Jeff got way too
late to the Keys way too late it's literally
like why did he take so much time he took too
much time thinking about it you heard the tape
go for the key but meanwhile he was like I'll
look at him and maybe I like him like who are you
and then they're like then they're like crying in
pain we learned it with the first woman and then
he goes to get the key and he doesn't even look
what what's who's standing back there I mean Jeff
Jeff I had some struggles in there I got mad at
him also when one door you guys know I talk about
this every time I do not like when people leave a
weapon behind and it also really bugged me that
Jeff saw the door close behind him in the first
door I'm like take a thing and shove it behind
come on now but then I guess was the door did the
door ever lock I kind of looked like it locked it
was very nice so I think even he did put something
in it would like crush it it would crush it okay
that would make me feel better I would still I
would still really like it if a character put a
thing there and then it crushed it at least you
tried at least you tried do something smart yeah
sometimes I just get so irritated that they don't
do certain things but the I mean I did have a lot
of fun watching this but it was nasty gross like
yeah yeah it was super gross I will say I
said it during as we were watching it but
something I really did appreciate appreciate
about the movie was the fact that each one is
very different from the last one and they're all
these weirdly connected movies even though there's
individual stories that were taking place that
on the surface don't seem connected but through
jigsaw and through the games that they're playing
they have like this through line and I like that
it's interesting because I've never seen I don't
I don't watch a ton of horror but I've never seen
um a franchise where the antagonist or the person
who's doing the the murders or the killings or
whatnot or become a prominent main character in
the stories because the first one yeah he would
like they kind of teased him and then you reveal
that he was the Dead Guy the whole time the second
one it was like uh almost like a Hannibal lecture
kind of thing like they're they're both sitting in
the room so he was a character in that second one
but I think it being the most prominent of like
oh we're spending a majority of this story with
Amanda with Jigsaw and with this doctor and that
that took more screen time than the game with
the husband did yeah and I was like okay very
interesting very interesting that this is the
route we're going with it my thing is like okay
he's dead she's dead who's gonna continue this
game or is it just like a series of of games that
he's planted for like because it was like right
multiple because like to not hear here's the thing
why I keep thinking like how do they kill them
off because to not hear his voice narrating of
like Jeff your game like it's gonna be weird to
hear another voice uh and maybe that's why they
made him more prominent because he's a great actor
and maybe I don't know they were just like we need
to show jigsaw guy more but it is going to be
weird to not hear his voice if they have to if
they killed him and then maybe he sets up one more
game but like there's so many of these there's
no way he's like he's dead and he's set up like
eight more games so there has to be another like
narrator or jigsaw person obviously who's it gonna
be I don't know will I be mad about the voice
in the background for a hot second because I've
gotten used to this guy talking uh he's a staple
he's our he's a staple saw guy he's he's there for
Comfort like okay yeah you're like okay I get it
yeah he's going to take us through it he's going
to be the voice behind the tapes of like you mess
this up that was a bad impression I tried though
would you like to play a game ah that was pretty
good thank you I mean guys I don't have a lot of
thoughts except that I had I did have a lot of fun
but like gross like I want it to be a little less
gross like please get out of the pig juice way
sooner than we were in it also the foot twists at
the top y'all I mean it's it this one was intense
I really liked it I'm gonna rate it eight out of
ten the twists at the end with Amanda I didn't
see coming um yeah I in I enjoyed that I mean
what do you how much what a what do you think
what's your rating what's your I I liked it uh I
thought it was grosser than the other two I didn't
like the twist as much as the first two because
the other two blew my mind like I kind of like
put pieces together during the first one with the
second one caught me way off guard and this third
one I think the twist was cool and I liked how it
related to the characters it was more the second
one was was character based as well but I think
the fact that it dealt more with the people that
were the perpetrators of this whole game yeah
and it being a a game about her I thought was
was clever um but yeah I will say I I enjoyed it
I'm still having a great time with these movies
uh I will say I will give this one like a seven
seven out of seven and a half I'm down with that
ten yeah yeah I like it uh any last thoughts you
got before we say sayonara oh this is gross uh me
and Greg watched Slither and this is probably like
five times grosser than that so I uh I don't know
what's gonna happen next but um yeah these movies
have been a ride so far yeah they have been a
lot of fun this was super gnarly we love you guys
don't forget to leave a like leave a comment tell
us what other scary movies we should watch and
just tell us that we look cool and that you like
our t-shirts and you know the good stuff all the
good stuff we didn't plan this by the way we just
happened and we were like hey hey and that's it
we love you and we'll see you on the next one bye